climate change is forcing millions of
people across the world to leave their
homes and their livelihoods it is fast
becoming one of the main causes of
forced migration and the situation is
likely to get much worse without urgent
action the un secretary general has said
climate change is now found to be the
key factor accelerating all other
drivers of force displacement so ella
given the urgency of this what needs to
be done
well we need to make sure that the kinds
of climate impacts which are driving
people to either leave their homes
within and move within their countries
or to move internationally are addressed
and i mean the primary thing that we
need to do is make sure that this
doesn't get any worse and that means
tackling climate change by reducing our
emissions
anna whose responsibility is it is it
the responsibility of richer nations to
help those who are most vulnerable
absolutely i mean i think the key kind
of principle to lay down is we all want
to treat others how we expect to be
treated everyone who experiences the
loss of livelihood everyone who
experiences the loss of safety deserves
um you know sanctuary if they're seeking
sanctuary and safety if they're seeking
if they seek an alternative livelihood
so um you know the countries that are
experiencing the worst uh impact in
terms of climate change they're actually
losing land
farmland other resources
other countries that have uh done the
least to um to cause the the global
heating that we're experiencing and uh
the uk and other rich countries have the
resources to fund the adaptation have
the resources to fund uh the sort of um
loss and damage um
that um that these countries have been
requesting um so that's what we need to
do we've got the resources to do it and
the uk
particularly as it still holds the corp
presidency should use this moment really
and its international influence and its
resources to finance um adaptation and
loss of damage
and
ella it's not just an issue for poorer
nations is it if you look at what's
happening in canada right now you look
to the us during hurricane season the
australian wildfires what we saw in
europe
over the summer those extreme weather
events causing internal displacement
is it surprising then that there isn't
more urgency about this more urgent
action being taken
when we put it like that maybe it's
surprising but the the fact of the
matter is that if it doesn't affect us
directly or we don't think it affects us
directly we're more um likely to to
ignore it and pretend it's not an issue
the thing is it's going to affect all of
us it already affects all of us climate
impacts are being felt
here in the uk they're being felt in
canada they're being felt in the usa
they're being felt in the developing and
developed world and the fact is it's
going to get worse especially if we do
the little we're doing already to adapt
and to mitigate climate change the more
warming we see in the future the more
devastating these impacts are going to
become and we absolutely have to do
everything that we can to make sure that
the worst impacts of climate change are
avoided
and what about those climate finance and
adaptation pledges made at cop 26 then
anna are they going to make any
difference
of course every step makes a difference
and i think the acknowledgement that the
issues of adaptation loss and damage
just transition have had at cop26 are
steps forward but you know so far mostly
its words uh so far
we have not seen anywhere near the
amount of financing that the most
effective country affected countries are
actually requesting
and the other thing is um one of the
things that you know i was in in the
global trade union delegation at cop26
and one of the things that we were
really calling for is that climate
finance that money that rich countries
put in to help poorer countries adapt or
mitigate
climate change
that those funds uh must be genuinely
fit for purpose that they must have
safeguards to protect human rights
including indigenous rights including
women's rights including labor rights
and that's not something that we've seen
yet so there's a lot
a lot of work still to be done in terms
of the international negotiations and
even more work to be done in terms of
securing the right amount of results